je peux voir ce qui est dans la voiture
l'intérieur on joint le mec là qui va
conduire là on est dans la cellule à il
a mis des petits mots au mur en train de
jouer que sa balle en fait d'accord ok
j'ai compris combien chamallow alors si
les nouveaux colis yes nouvelle optique
de saint-marc moi tt ça dans quelques
jours sa caméra de surveillance de
presse vise parce que dans le studio il
ya quand même pas mal de matos il ya
quand même un peu de matos là un peu là
bas un peu ici un peu par là un peu par
là encore un peu par là un peu par là
donc faut commencer à penser à sécuriser
un peu tout ça on en reparlera dans
quelques jours aujourd'hui on va parler
toute chose on va parler des nouveaux
iphone ça fait quelques jours que je les
teste j'ai avec moi en permanence tout
le temps le modèle max je le prends je
le torture jeu de secours quand même de
tous les côtés donc on fait plein plein
de choses avec up revient pas avec ceux
fixés ce max et j'ai plein de choses à
vous dire là dessus alors je vous
explique comment ça va se passer
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en faire un test d'unix
s-max et du xs je me donnais mon retour
complet sur le produit vous dire en
termes de performances autonomie prise
en main design d'écran tout ça va faire
un tour complet dessus complet oui sauf
sur un point le dernier point qu'on
attendra dans une vidéo à part c'est la
partie photo vidéo est vraiment focus
qui a été fait là dessus donc on va
prendre le temps de le regarder
tranquillement sur notre vidéo
donc ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui c'est
que on va le chéquier ces deux
smartphones puis vous allez me dire vous
en commentaire ce que vous en pensez
petit aparté est-ce que vous avez
regardé la vidéo hier sur le midi et
deux c'est pas le cas je t'invite à
aller voir parce que c'est pas un iphone
mais il est plutôt cool pour les besoins
d'un vidéo j'enlève ma coque rhinochill
mais je vous conseille franchement de
toujours la garde avec vous pour
protéger votre smartphone je vous aurais
dû une fois de plus que nos schild a pas
mal de produits très intéressant ça vous
intéresse vous avez un lien en bas dans
la description
oui toujours un truc est hyper bizarre
lorsque je vais tester des iphone tout
s'explique
ça c'est l'iphone que j'utilise tout le
temps c'est mon iphone 6 s vous
avait à côté l'iphone 10 aces et à côté
l'iphone 10 s max on a donc trois iphone
trois fois le même fond d'écran c'est
exactement la même chose et moi y'a
toujours tout qui me chiffonne un peu là
dedans c'est vraiment un truc tout bête
c'est quelque chose de très très très
personnel mais quand je passe de mon
iphone avec ce fond d'écran avec mes
applications avec tout ce que j'ai à
l'intérieur et que je transfère pas son
très intuitive et très facile d'ailleurs
je voulais montrer dans la dernière
vidéo justement sur le n boxing je
transfère sur un nouvel iphone
je vais l'impression au final de
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour avoir le
même iphone
alors je sais que c'est pas du tout mon
iphone je sais c'est pas même iphone
c'est pas le même produit
mais c'est la sensation que ça me fait
et c'est juste ça qui est relativement
bizarre je sais les produits sont pas du
tout les mêmes
on n'a pas les mêmes écrans lcd oled
c'est un vieux truc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement récent avec toutes les
nouvelles techno à l'intérieur donc je
le sais j'en ai conscience
intellectuellement je sais mais ça fait
quand même hyper bizarre petit aparté on
ferme la parenthèse
ce sont vraiment les mêmes iphone la
grosse différence que vous allez avoir
c'est l'écran et la batterie vous avez
un écran de 5 des 8 pouces un écran de
6,5 pouces et le plus grand écran jamais
fait par apple sur ses iphone une
batterie forcément qui va être plus
puissante pour s'adapter à la différence
de l'écran qui va consommer beaucoup
plus ont des écrans oled compatible hd
herbe division des écrans super retina
et surtout super lumineux là je vous
emmène à l'extérieur là il ya du soleil
vous voyez bien c'est insolite de mode
septembre n'est pas sur la feuille du
mois d'août néanmoins la luminosité
pousser à fond on y voit extrêmement
bien on est en plein jour car dès mes
mains comme elles sont exposées on y
voit extrêmement bien et cet écran est
vraiment hyper agréable alors je sais
pas si vous vous rendez bien compte tout
de suite au travers de la caméra mais on
voit vraiment bien il ya un vrai confort
de lecture
cet écran est vraiment extrêmement
lumineux bien plus lumineux que les
samsung galaxy s 9 et est notre plus la
luminosité de l'écran de l'iphone 10
aces et 10 s max est complètement
bluffante c'est extrêmement agréable de
le regarder que vous soyez la nuit
forcément c'est très facile mais en
plein jour complètement et c'est ça qui
est vraiment génial avec ce smartphone à
peu nous annoncer un écran super retina
encore plus lumineux et là pour le coup
ils n'ont pas menti pour regarder vos
séries vos films youtube tout ce que
vous voulez c'est vraiment hyper
appréciable mais là où c'est vraiment
très impressionnant c'est lorsque vous
arrivez sur
max là vous avez un confort visionnage
qui complètement incroyable regardez la
différence
d'un côté vous avez ici l'iphone 5,8
pouces et l'iphone 6,5 pouces il ya
vraiment une énorme différence
vous avez un confort de lecture sur le
6,5 et complètement incomparable
l'expérience n'est pas du tout la même
vous n'allez pas du tout apprécié de la
même manière c'est vraiment juste ou
faux cils et c'est vrai que moi
j'utilise depuis quelques jours je me
suis complètement habitués à utiliser
cet écran 6,5 pouces c'est complètement
hallucinant mais c'est pas tout parce
que vous avez aussi une qualité audio
qui est complètement dingue haut
parleurs stéréo
je vais vous mettre le son à fond vous
allez voir haut-parleurs qui situe ici
deuxième haut parleurs qui utilise deux
par là
le format est quand même impressionnant
sur la version max l'audio sur cet
iphone est vraiment vraiment vraiment
hawks ne le serait pas et maintenant on
va tester avec directement up la prise
jack
ah bah non c'est vrai on peut pas prise
on est là pour le couvre pas de test en
plus de ça apple a supprimé de ses
boîtes l'adaptateur pour lightning
priziac qu'il mettait jusqu'à présent
c'est très très très très dommage si
vous le voulez il faut l'acheter
directement sur le site d'apple
pour 9 euros quand ça fait râler
vraiment fondamentalement ce grand écran
est bien mais il a aussi un désavantage
pour utiliser à une main c'est quand
même relativement compliqué par exemple
vous voulez envoyer un sms vous
l'arrivée dans les chiffres
ce quartier un peu les doigts est allé
chercher en bas ici c'est compliqué on a
toujours je risque de le faire tomber
très clairement ce smartphone quand on
vous tapez des sms quand on veut
l'utiliser comme ça il faut utiliser à
demain pour pas risquer de le faire
tomber et pour coup ce serait vraiment
très embêtant d'ailleurs je vous invite
quand même à mettre une coque pour
protéger à la différence de l'iphone 10s
vous pouvez utiliser à une main très
facilement le format est beaucoup plus
compact le reconnaître que je suis
vraiment tombé amoureux de ce format là
de ce grand format 6,5 pouces au niveau
de l'écran parce que je trouve
extrêmement confortable et ça croyez moi
ça change vraiment la donne par contre
aller chercher comme ça quand vous êtes
dans la rue quand vous marchez avec vous
avez qu'une seule manne libre et que
vous devez aller chercher des choses de
l'autre côté de l'écran
c'est une gymnastique un peu dangereuse
et à chaque fois j'ai franchement par le
faire tomber
c'est pas le seul point négatif que
j'aurai accès téléphone lorsque je veux
le mettre dans la poche c'est pareil ils
arrivent juste ici tout en haut là donc
j'ai peur
en pliant la jambe de risquer de le
faire sortir de le faire partir d'autant
plus que lorsque je mets une coque il ya
encore plus grand encore plus massif
j'ai encore plus peur de le faire tomber
lorsque je vais m'asseoir notamment dans
les transports en commun dans les
transports publics
là j'ai peur qu'ils se barrent qui se
fasse la malle et manoirs trouvé qu'un
iphone 1300 euros qui est je ne sais
d'où l'autre modèle bien évidemment est
beaucoup plus compact il va très
facilement dans votre poche et là pour
le coup vous voyez j'ai de la place
ça me rassure d'ailleurs il ya une
question à se poser sur un smartphone
double quand même plus de 1000 euros est
ce que ça voudrait pas coup prendre une
assurance
je sais il ya plein de personnes moi le
premier qui suis relativement allergique
aux assurances sur les smartphones mais
ça ne paraît pas déconnant d'assurer un
produit qui coûte 1300 euros
d'autant plus que c'est un produit que
vous avez tout le temps avec vos la main
qu'on peut très facilement perdre très
facilement cerveau les très facilement
cassé il faut le protéger c'est une
évidence mais l'assuré c'est pas
forcément complètement stupide quitte
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire le design j'en ai déjà parlé
il est relativement inchangé par rapport
à l'iphone de l'année dernière mais des
petits changements au niveau de
l'antenne que vous allez retrouver ici
je l' ai déjà parlé dans la vidéo de
hunt boxing une mise à part ces petits
changements ils sont vraiment vraiment
similaires on est sur une version s
on est donc sur une mise à jour de
l'iphone 10 on n'est pas sur un tout
nouveau modèle pour avoir un tout
nouveau modèle il va falloir attendre
l'année prochaine
parce qu'apple tout comme samsung
renouvellent leurs modèles tous les deux
ans le taux de renouvellement des
smartphones chez les consommateurs chez
vous chez moi augmente on va plus changé
son smartphone tous les ans tous les
deux en règle générale donc les
constructeurs s'adaptent et sortent un
nouveau flagship tout neuf tout beau
tous les deux ans avec les mises à jour
au milieu c'est ce qu'on aime chez
samsung avec le f8 s9 ce qu'on a avec
l'iphone iphone 10 iphone 10 s donc si
vous voulez vraiment de la nouveauté
chez apple il va falloir attendre
l'année prochaine
néanmoins ce smartphone même s'il a pas
de la nouveauté d'un point de vue
esthétique et en termes de
fonctionnalités il a de vraies belles
mises à jour en termes de performances
en termes de photos en termes
d'autonomie c'est quand même aussi
relativement mieux pour la partie photo
va falloir attendre quelques jours parce
que je sortirai un test complet
ça nécessite vraiment vraiment vraiment
un test complet vous allez voir pour la
performance
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux parce
que ces deux nouveaux iphone on la puce
à 12 bionic
l'année dernière il ya eu la puce à 11
bionique là c'est une mise à jour de la
puissance bionique cette puce deuxième
génération est beaucoup plus rapide de
10 à 15%
une autonomie qui a amélioré une puce
graphique qui est complètement améliorée
et surtout le north island jeunes
l'intelligence artificielle vous
permettra d'aller beaucoup plus loin
notamment l'utilisation de réalité
augmentée parce que chez apple on croit
pas beaucoup à la réalité virtuelle qui
enferme un peu trop selon tim cook mais
on croit beaucoup à la réalité augmentée
et c'est justement là dessus qu'apple
travaille énormément et l'ont présentée
l'année dernière déjà sur leur ipad
ensuite sur leur iphone et là ils vont
encore plus loin pour utiliser la
réalité augmentée que ce soit vraiment
performant il faut derrière de la
puissance de calcul
d'où ces puces de la série bionic on a
eu la 11
on alla 12 on aura probablement l'année
prochaine la 13
pareil quand même relativement logique
parce que c'est plus elles vous
permettent non seulement d'avoir un
smartphone qui est beaucoup plus rapide
mais aussi une autonomie accrue c'est un
peu ce que font tous les fabricants de
puces
vous avez par exemple le keirin 981 cas
présentés huawei a pas très longtemps à
l'ifa se guérit 980 a pour objectif de
gagner en puissance de gagner un point
de détail pour vous des tours et pour
savoir qui vous êtes ce que vous faites
au niveau des photos donc par extension
pour vous apposez de la réalité
augmentée directement à travers vos
écrans mais également pour faire gagner
en autonomie c'est à dire être capable
d'optimiser votre machine pour aller
puiser dans les performances au moment
où vous avez besoin d'aucune machines
toujours plus puissantes et une
autonomie accrue c'est exactement la
même chose avec qualcomm et le nouveau
snapdragon qui va arriver d'ici la fin
de l'année
et c'est exactement la même chose avec
cette puce à 12 bionique made in apple
sur un jeu comme peu ivg typiquement ça
marche super bien ça ne la quitte pas
c'est vraiment hyper hyper fluide sur en
doute ou l'iphone 10 s max obtient le
score de 313 1466 si on regarde sur le
site en tout ou par rapport aux autres
produits ios il à se classer largement
devant l'ipad pro qui un score de 273
1602 alors que l'iphone dit de l'année
dernière était classé en troisième
position avec le score de 230 3698
autant dire qu'il a tout misé et si on
compare par rapport aux scores qu'on a
sur android avec le chiot me black shark
un score de 289 1414 autant vous dire
qu'en termes de puissance de performance
l'iphone 10 s max est largement au
dessus
j'ai également d'enceinte est en tout 26
marques sur l'iphone 10 aces et on
arrive également au score de 362 1461
pendant tous les cas ce qu'on voit c'est
que c'est vraiment une machine hyper
performantes hyper puissante et qu'elle
absolument rien à envier aux autres et
bien au contraire aller même largement
au dessus il ya un autre point qui m'a
extrêmement bluffer sur cet iphone c'est
l'autonomie
il a duré pas moins de trois jours
le troisième jour fin de journée ils
étaient dans le rouge mais il a quand
même duré trois jours alors on sait que
tonomy ça dépend vrai
d'autres utilisations néanmoins je tiens
à préciser qu' à ma carte sim dedans que
j'utilise pour les appels pour les sms
pour mes différentes applis youtube
creator studio les emails et où il a
tenu quasiment trois jours complets
je suis vraiment surpris du coup j'y
vais un peu plus fort sans l'utilisation
il tient deux jours sans aucun problème
donc si vous êtes vraiment un sauvage en
termes d'utilisation que vous êtes tout
le temps sans vos applications tout le
temps en train de jouer tout le temps
tout le temps tout en dessus déjà vous
avez vous flinguer les yeux je vous
conseille un petit peu de ralentir parce
que l'homme est à mon avis quand même
relativement un sauvage
mais si vous êtes vraiment tout le temps
dessus vous tiendrez une très grosse
journée une journée et demie sans aucun
problème et si vous l'utilisez comme moi
pas tout le temps des bons coups deux
jours sans problème si vous utilisez
façon un peu plus raisonner un peu plus
cool
vous pourrez tenir trois jours c'est
vraiment impressionnant en termes
d'autonomie et c'est là dessus qu'on
voit aussi que la puce à 12
bionic fait vraiment le job alors apple
a annoncé l' autonomie supérieure de 1h
à 1h30 par rapport aux différents iphone
ça vient aussi de mon utilisation à moi
bien évidemment si vous utilisez
beaucoup
forcément il a beaucoup consommé et
puisqu'on parle de réalité augmentée on
va tester une application dédiée à la
réalité augmentée c'est l'application
légaux voilà donc le commissariat de
police légaux et c'est vrai que
l'expérience en réalité augmentée est
juste ouf je peux m'approcher aller voir
vraiment ce qui se passe ces officines
qu'est-ce qui a par là à la hauteur
police je peux voir ce qui est dans la
voiture l'intérieur on joint le mec là
qu'il va conduire
là on est dans la cellule il a mis des
petits mots au mur en train de jouer que
sa balle en fait d'accord ok j'ai
compris
on est une vraie vraie fluidité ça
réagit tout de suite c'est vraiment
hyper hyper hyper hyper bluffant on est
donc sur un iphone beaucoup plus
performant d'ailleurs on a fait ça dit
version 2 beaucoup plus rapide selon
apple pour tout vous dire je n'aurai
absolument pas compte je le met face à
moi il me reconnaît y déverrouille je
faisais sur le modèle de l'année
dernière pour moi c'était vraiment la
même chose je pense pas consenti à la
différence effectivement fait seydi
fonctionne très bien
maintenant les mesures et au millième de
seconde c'est toujours un peu compliqué
après ce qu'apple nous annonce reçue
c'est aussi un fils ait dit beaucoup
plus sécurisée et ça pour coup c'est
pareil qu'on peut pas le mesurer
mais en tout cas c'est très bien
maintenant la question fatidique
doit-on changer
son smartphone pour un iphone 10 aces ou
un iphone 10 s max alors je n'ai pas la
réponse absolue
ça serait prête ensuite vous dire oui
vous devez changer de nom vous est pas
changé néanmoins je vous donne quelques
clés si vous avez un iphone de l'année
dernière si vous avez l'iphone 10 cru
2010 est pour moi il ya globalement très
peu d'intérêt pour changer de l'iphone
10 à l'iphone 10 s effectivement il est
plus performant effectivement à
l'appareil photo est mieux mais ça on le
verra d'ici quelques jours
effectivement il va plus vite mais celui
ci est très actuelle va très vite
fonctionne très bien
donc globalement je ne vois absolument
pas l'intérêt de changer votre iphone
d'autant plus que tout de suite dans des
budgets très conséquent ci-après vous
avez beaucoup d'argent et que 1200 euros
pour vous c'est une pacotille
eh bien vous ne pouvez y aller de toute
façon dont cet iphone est très bien ça
ses premiers points deuxième point si
vous avez comme moi un vieil iphone
iphone 6 s et que vous en avez comme moi
ras le pompon et que vous vous dites
comme moi il faut que je le change
d'autant plus que j'en ai plein entre
les mains et je me dis mon embrayage
titre falloir y passer dans ce cas là il
ya un vrai sens de changer d'autant plus
que sur des iphones 6s 7,8 c'est un peu
moins vrai mais quand même il ya une
vraie vraie vraie différence
significative mais les iphone 8 et 8
plus me paraissent quand même moins au
sol est de point de vue performance
parce qu'ils ont la puce à 11 bionique
mais ils paraissent complètement de sol
est du point de vue du design parce que
vous avez ce viol hook qui n'est plus du
tout actuelle en 2018 donc si vous avez
un vieil iphone un vieux smartphone
android ou quoi que ce soit oui ça vaut
le coup de changer ça c'est le deuxième
point troisième point si vous avez un
smartphone android qui est récent type s
8 s9 note 9 note 8 ou alors un pépin pro
est ce que ça vaut le coup de changer et
de passer sur cet iphone
10 16 sous iphone 10 s max pour moi ça
vaut pas forcément le coup parce que on
est effectivement sur un smartphone très
performant on est sur un smartphone qui
est extrêmement bien fini qui est très
cher et je peux vous assurer qu'il vaut
son prix même si la question du prix
fait toujours débat
il vaut son prix mais ça on en reparle
dans une prochaine vidéo parce que j'ai
vous détailler le tarif de l'iphone ce
qu'a expliqué pourquoi il vaut son prix
vous dire tout ce que vous en pensez à
ce moment là en commentaire mais si vous
avez un smartphone android haut de gamme
je pense pas que ça vaille le coup
attendez à mon avis plus tôt l'année
prochaine du côté de chez samsung il va
y avoir du changement avec le x10 qui
devrait naître une grande claque à
sorèze plus l'arrivée potentielle d'un
samsung galaxy x smartphones à écran
pliable qu'il va arriver aussi
probablement l'année prochaine si rwe
n'ont d'ailleurs pas mal de choses qui
vont se passer en 2019
donc je vous conseille un petit peu
d'attendre quelques mois pour moi ce que
ça dit d'autant plus que l'année
prochaine
apple a également renouvelé sa gamme
avec probablement un design revu repensé
donc bon dans la mesure où vous avez un
smartphone actuel je suis pas sûr que ça
vaille le coup
maintenant la question peut toujours se
poser est ce que ça vaut le coût net
1200-1300 jusqu'à 1600 euros en plus de
1600 euros sur un smartphone
la réponse ne m'appartient pas elle vous
appartient vous il y en a pour toutes
les bourses
ça ça dépend vraiment de vous de vos
moyens de vos besoins de vos envies donc
ça reste très personnel voilà quand je
vous ai glissé quelques clés à vous
maintenant d'en faire ce que vous voulez
merci à vous alors je vous dis restez
connectés parce que si quelques jours à
faire un comparatif iphone 10 d'ercis
iphone 10 aces comme ça on va regarder
si ça vaut le coup de changer oui ou non
vous est déjà donné mon point de vue
mais on va quand même comparé point par
point par un petit peu quelles sont les
différences notables et puis pourquoi
pas si vous devez acheter un nouvel
iphone cette année est-ce que ça
vaudrait pas le coup d'aller sur
l'iphone 10,2 des milices est ça on m'a
parlé il ya quelques jours vous invite
donc à faire une seule chose c'est à
vous abonner et à la sécurité
[Musique]